it is the 25th anniversary that's true
um we are here at quakecon that's true
but i don't think it would be virtually
here at quakecon you know in spirit
that's right here
uh i don't think it would be
a quakecon if we didn't have
an announcement
you my friend are correct
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
amazing how wild is that you love to see
it i mean i'm trying to think back to
quake being on consoles and we're
talking like saturn nintendo 64 days so
this is this is pretty wild
and marty do you want to walk us through
just some of like the
top line points of how this
what this offers uh a lot of new players
that are maybe just coming in for the
first time or maybe they're familiar
with quick a little bit
yeah absolutely i mean it for us it was
important to to
be authentic and um create a genuine
quake
experience that that uh that is is what
people love i mean we've talked so much
about what it meant to to players um
what what it's meant to the industry um
to to to basically you know kind of
bring it back at the 25th anniversary
bring it to a new uh a whole new
audience of players or or to to players
who've been with us for the last 25
years um kind of doing both of those
things with this visually enhanced
version um is is really what it was all
about um and the team has done a great
job with it we have um
xbox series x and s and uh as well as
playstation five where we'll have 4k
support and 120 hertz support which is
awesome um from uh from a multiplayer
perspective obviously you know we've
touched on it but but multiplayer quake
was such a you know such a such a big
deal um and and for for this release we
have um uh
obviously full multiplayer support both
local and and uh and internet um a local
has four players split screen as well as
four player co-op uh we have cross play
on uh you know when you're when you're
playing uh online multiplayer so really
a great you know
just a great version of quake um for
again
people who've been with us for a long
time or you know if if you've kind of
gotten into the recent uh scene around
uh around this style of game i i love to
see there's there's almost been a
resurgence of this style of game uh
within the indie scene
on these fast you know fast-paced fluid
um you know first-person shooters and um
i think doom's been part of that but but
they all really go back to quake and so
if you're a fan of that scene but you've
never you know you've never played a
quake game you know this is this is the
original uh and uh and and it's worth
picking up
absolutely awesome yeah well said and
then kevin it's not just visual
enhancements right we've got some pretty
cool audio stuff going on as well in the
enhanced version
we do we do i mean i do want to give a
shout out to tonight dive and you know
that's that's the team that's working
with us uh
on the project
back in in uh i guess it was quakecon
2019
uh some of their team members sat around
a lunch table with me and and uh
and we discussed this idea they're huge
fans
uh of the game and you know
if you've played doom 64
you know you've played a night div uh
title with us right um these guys
specialize in bringing back
yeah bringing back these uh these
classic games and really making sort of
an archival version of them uh that
it plays like the game you remember it
looks like the game you remember but
it's better and so uh you know i just
want to give a shout out to those guys
and you know the the the effort they put
into it so you know on the sound side of
course we you know we we included the
original soundtrack
um we also went back to
our uh you know our archives of the
source sounds and uh uh
released them and we'll be releasing
them now in 22 kilohertz rather than 11
kilohertz
uh so a lot of you know improvements to
try to get the best quality version of
quake out there in the hands of players
uh so you know we're really excited
about it
awesome very cool
um and york i'm gonna toss this one over
to you so you've been talking about you
know playing having played quake single
player obsessively um and also about the
modding scene so what about
mission packs in this new updated
version
um and also uh what about the modding
scene in general like how are are mods
going to be supported
the enhanced version comes with the two
mission packs a source of armageddon and
also
the solution of eternity
which is really really great
and in addition and also i'm also very
happy to say that we have a contribution
from the machine games quake modding
group as well
both dimension of the past and an
all-new
mod called dimension of the machine will
also be included in
in this version of quake which is super
cool cool yeah brand brand new
mission pack oh my god
and the game will definitely support
mods amazing for for pc already now and
support for curated mods for console
will be
added later that is so cool like not
only is it coming to new platforms where
quake has never been on right um to an
all you know in an all new audience
really yeah um but they're going to
check out some of these cool community
creations
and you know there's going to be post
launch support for that i know so cool
and just a spoiler
i've played
the new machine games edition add-on and
it is rad like you said your i can tell
that you guys are using new tools to
make because i was like what is this is
this even quick this is incredible like
architecture everything you guys blew it
out of the water so that's really cool
yeah it's it's awesome and yeah i mean
it really is fantastic how far things
have come and those guys did it you know
machine games did an incredible job with
it for sure
very exciting to see and again free
content once you get the game you can
just download it you can choose to
download or delete any of these things
you can keep tidy your own build it's
all pretty sweet and self-contained
that's wild it's pretty round all right
we want to thank marty
kevin and york one more time for joining
us guys thank you so much and thank you
for making this last 25 years a hell of
a ride
thanks guys
thank you
thanks